talk to Jacob and see what Jacobs got to
say he's in Florida hey Jacob your
question for Chris and me hey I'm
calling home to ask about kind of a good
problem to have but I don't know how to
approach it so I am estimated based on
my calculations in the next nine months
at the end of nine months to make around
45 to 50 K all saved up no debt no
nothing I'm kind of wondering what to do
with that considering I want to go into
law and that's just debt I don't have to
incur and pay off over time but I'll get
up until that point I'm sorry old are
you 19 okay so you're in college now yes
and you want to go to law school yes and
you're gonna have $45,000 towards that
yes well I'm actually asking should I
instead maybe invest it like in the
stock market or day trading or maybe go
on the real estate and brito um like
rental management property or should I
just save it and hope for the best so I
don't have to pay off that debt when it
come okay while dave is catching his
breath
Jacob cuz you said day trading now I
want you to listen to me young man you
are a very intelligent young man you
don't accidentally get forty five to
fifty thousand dollars saved up on
accident right so you sacrifice for this
didn't you yeah okay we're not going to
Vegas to spin the wheel to see if this
all works out because yeah yeah so if
you day trading that's exactly what it's
tantamount to doing so we're not gonna
do that
okay not doing that I don't like that
idea at all let me give you the numbers
dude seventy eight percent that's all of
them of day traders lose money in a
calendar year
yeah like the same statistics yeah so
why would you even bring it up I knew
that statistic is you're not different
let don't be arrogant cuz arrogance
right on what happens right before you
lose your $45,000 quickly yeah you're
not
exception unit you do not have the stock
market beat at 19 years old I don't
think I do then don't play in it no okay
the mindset around this listen Jacob
with where you are it's not an accident
with what you've done love the idea of
you thinking about law school and
looking at this what I want you to do is
to a be prepared to use the money you
have saved up toward law school okay
okay and I want you listen to me talk to
you you're gonna get ready to use that
money and then I want you to start to
apply for scholarships and get focused
on this and I want you to make a
decision Jacob because I remember I
coached a guy that went through law
school two hundred fifty thousand
dollars in law school loans never took
the bar so I don't want you to be
interested in law I need you to be
passionate about it before you pursue it
okay so I need you to make some
decisions go sit down and talk to an
attorney
sit down and talk and understand the
length of time it's gonna take this is
gonna be an all-out effort and you need
to say focus but I like the habit you
have of saving just ending up just
hearing that story makes me want to end
up in a bar oh oh no Dave that was the
truth I mean it was real I know he took
fifty thousand dollars in law school
loans never sat for the bar decided to
go a different route into Social Work
Jacob I want you to take the
intellectual energy that you have and
the ability you haven't applied to going
to the law school debt free yes for
forty five thousand and any other money
you can get scrape together while you're
still in undergrad the best return on
investment mathematically superior to
day trading which that's a low bar
that's a squirrel bar squirrel king it
over that bar but superior to investing
in real estate superior to investing in
anything the best investment Jacob you
can make is in Jacob hmm the return on
investment of you going to law school
debt free and coming out and passing
your bar and becoming an attorney the
the increase in income you will have
because you invested in you because of
that field of study will allow you to
make a lot more than you would have made
on forty five thousand dollars I mean
think about if you if you put forty five
thousand dollars towards law school and
you come out and you make X number of
tens of thousands dollars more than the
rich cat walking around right or you
make 10% on your forty five thousand
four thousand five hundred dollars right
so the best investment a college student
can make if they're in a quality field
of study is in themselves to go through
school debt-free hold on we're gonna
give you a copy of Anthony O'Neill's
book debt-free degree and it yes
it does apply to law school and no don't
make the assumption that law school
always means debt we know lots of people
that have gone through law school debt
free it is a hard trip but paying off a
hundred grands a hard trip to do